today I'm going to show you the top
three ways to create more happiness part
two let's talk about the third and final
way you can create happiness in your
life I call it becoming one with the
Muse there are a ton of different names
for this but the one that you're
probably most familiar with already is
what's called entering a flow State this
is when you're engaged in an activity
with a hundred percent of your focus
every action every movement and thought
flows out of you effortlessly you don't
have to think your body just does
Studies have actually found that when we
are in the Flow State our brains flood
our system with large quantities of
dopamine endorphins and serotonin these
are all extremely pleasurable
neurotransmitters so how exactly does
one enter the Flow State more often well
it's quite simple you probably already
have a couple of things that you enjoy
doing it can be any hobby any sort of
work or skill so long as it allows you
to be creative in some way and you just
have to make a habit of spending some
time every single day playing around
with this activity that you enjoy